hi I'm wishing to Las tea and I'm
finders here braving talent Roger and
here in Dallas as i have y GL and i've
been asked on to the russian yet what
would you like to be remembered for
which was a difficult question to answer
that for me right now at the stage in
life i'm doing babe metallic and really
on a mission to try to improve the mob
of education through very different
thinking because right now we're liquid
world is the existing formal education
system is failing level and the gap
between the supply of talents from the
formal education system and the demand
of talent in industry growing wider and
wider area so what I'm trying to do
regret new talent is introduced a new
model of Education a new model
development of talent where more people
could reach their full potential by
connecting to employers and employees
that work at those companies and using
social media by joining our communities
on bradenton and allowing people to join
what I hope will one day be world's
largest school on in the cloud where
they can learn for free that you've been
doing the job that they might like to
undo my online dating or practicing the
skills they my legs are quiet so for me
that's that's my ambition right now and
thank you Andy Bockelman France asking
the question yet